All right, Mr. Ken Lane, whenever you're ready, we're going to sing a few of these songs. We hope you enjoy them.
好的，肯·莱恩先生，只要你准备好了，我们就来唱这几首歌。希望你们会喜欢。
Yeah, we hope you enjoy them. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
是的，希望你们会喜欢。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
What are you staring at? [SINGING] Brassieres. I dig a broad with no brassieres.
你在盯着什么看？[唱歌] 胸罩。我喜欢不穿胸罩的女人。
This is a recording from 1962 of Frank Sinatra, Dean Martin, and Sammy Davis Jr. performing in a club outside Chicago. And like everything else about Frank Sinatra, what's fascinating about this recording is how many different people he's able to be all at once. Cutting up on the one hand, and then turning around and singing the most vulnerable possible love songs on the other.
这是1962年弗兰克·辛纳屈、迪恩·马丁和小萨米·戴维斯在芝加哥郊外一家夜总会表演的录音。像弗兰克·辛纳屈的其他一切一样，这段录音最迷人的地方在于他能同时表现出多少种不同的人格。一方面在插科打诨，另一方面转过身又能唱出最脆弱动人的情歌。
[SINGING] When you're alone, who cares for starlit skies? Where does it hurt, baby? When you're alone.
[唱歌] 当你独自一人，谁会在乎星光灿烂的夜空？哪里受伤了，宝贝？当你独自一人时。
Not three minutes later, he's lashing into a gossip columnist he hates, Dorothy Kilgallen.
不到三分钟后，他又开始猛烈抨击他讨厌的八卦专栏作家多萝西·基尔加伦。
I've met many, many male finks. But I never met a female fink until I met Dorothy Kilgallen. How's that for an opener? [LAUGHTER] I wouldn't mind if she was a good-looking fink.
我见过很多很多卑鄙的男人。但在遇见多萝西·基尔加伦之前，我从未见过卑鄙的女人。这个开场白怎么样？[笑声] 要是她是个长得好看的卑鄙小人，我倒不介意。
"That such beautiful music should emerge from such vulgarity is one of life's great mysteries," The Washington Star once wrote.
《华盛顿星报》曾写道：“如此优美的音乐竟然出自如此粗俗之人，真是人生的一大谜团。”
The town where she came from, they had a beauty contest when she was 17 years old, and nobody won. There was a poor little Chinese kid. The boy was standing there. There was nobody else. They gave him the cup because he was better looking than the broads in the line.
她家乡那个小镇在她17岁那年举办过一场选美比赛，结果没人获胜。当时有个可怜的中国小男孩站在那里，除此之外没有别人。他们把奖杯颁给了他，因为他比排在那儿的那些女人们长得好看。
Then there's the way he is on stage with Sammy Davis Jr. In 1962, it was still groundbreaking for a mainstream white performer to be integrating his night club act at all. But a good portion of the act is just Sinatra and Martin telling Davis to get off the stage, and Davis pleading with them to stay.
还有他和小萨米·戴维斯同台演出时的样子。在1962年，对于主流白人表演者来说，让自己的夜总会表演多元化在当时还是具有突破性的。但节目中很大一部分内容就是辛纳屈和马丁叫戴维斯滚下台，而戴维斯恳求他们留住他。
You asked me out here. Can I sing with you guys? A couple of--
你们叫我出来的。我可以和你们一起唱吗？几个……
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey. I'll dance with you. I'll sing with you. I'll swim with you. I'll cut the lawn with you. I'll go to Bar Mitzvahs with you. But don't touch me.
嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿。我可以和你跳舞。我可以和你唱歌。我可以和你一起游泳。我可以和你一起割草。我可以和你一起去参加受诫礼。但别碰我。
A third of a century after this was recorded, what is, I think, most striking about it is how many of the jokes are simply about the fact that a black man is on stage with these white guys. I'm going to play you a big chunk of this because it's amazing.
这段录音过去了三分之一世纪，我认为最引人注目的是，很多笑话仅仅是因为一个黑人正与这些白人站在台上。我要给你们播放这段录音的一大段，因为它太不可思议了。
Well, now that you're out here, you might as well do something.
好吧，既然你已经出来了，你最好还是做点什么。
Might as well leave.
最好还是离开。
Hey, how come he got a white stool?
嘿，为什么他有个白色的凳子？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I tell you what. Ladies and gentlemen, may I offer some impersonations for you nice folks?
我告诉你们。女士们先生们，我可以为各位好心人表演几个模仿秀吗？
Sam, that's a good idea. Why don't you do Paul Revere, get on your horse and get the hell out of here. I tell you what. Do James Meredith of Mississippi.
萨米，这主意不错。你为什么不模仿保罗·里维尔，骑上你的马滚出这里。我跟你说。模仿一下密西西比州的詹姆斯·梅雷迪斯吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Help!
救命！
Ladies and gentlemen, my first impression is that of Mr. Frank Sinatra.
女士们先生们，我的第一个模仿秀是弗兰克·辛纳屈先生。
[SINGING] When somebody loves you, it's no good unless she loves you all the way.
[唱歌] 当有人爱你时，除非她全心全意地爱你，否则都是枉然。
Man, if you like him, you're going to be cuckoo about me. He's just-- you'll excuse the expression-- a carbon copy.
伙计，如果你喜欢他，那你一定会为我疯狂。他只是——请原谅我用这个词——一个翻版。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When Sammy Davis finally sings a duet with Sinatra, it is a duet between a black man and a white man that is unimaginable to hear it. You cannot imagine it being performed today by a black and a white man. It's one they performed for years, "Me and My Shadow."
当萨米·戴维斯终于与辛纳屈合唱时，那是一个黑人与白人之间的二重唱，听起来简直难以想象。你无法想象今天会有黑人和白人共同表演这首歌。这是他们表演多年的《我和我的影子》。
[SINGING TOGETHER, OVERLAPPING] Me and my shadow. Closer than pages that stick in a book. We're closer than ripples that  play in a brook. Strolling down the avenue. Wherever you'll find him, you'll find me, just look. Closer than a miser or  the bloodhounds to Liza, me.
[合唱，重叠] 我和我的影子。比粘在书页里的书签还要亲密。我们比在小溪中戏水的涟漪还要亲密。漫步在大街上。无论你在哪里找到他，你都会找到我，只要看看就知道了。比守财奴或追踪丽莎的猎犬还要亲密，我。
In Frank Sinatra, we see the history of the 20th century. In Frank Sinatra, as a Chicago writer named Rennie Sparks puts it, we don't just see a man, we see every man.
在弗兰克·辛纳屈身上，我们看到了20世纪的历史。正如芝加哥作家雷尼·斯帕克斯所说，在弗兰克·辛纳屈身上，我们看到的不仅仅是一个人，而是所有人。
Frank Sinatra is my father and my brother, my first boyfriend and my last. He's a frail boy crooner in a floppy bow tie. He's a thug smashing his fist through a wall when his shirts come back with too much starch. And he's a bewildered old man falling off his stool during "My Way." Shirley MacLaine says he let her stick her gum behind his ear during takes of Some Came Running . But he also liked to grab an ice cube from his drink thrusting it in the palm of a ga-ga fan and snarling, "Here, go skate around on it."
弗兰克·辛纳屈是我的父亲，也是我的兄弟，是我的初恋，也是我最后的爱人。他是一个穿着宽松领结、嗓音纤细的少年歌手。他是一个当衬衫上浆过多时，会挥拳砸穿墙壁的暴徒。他还是那个在唱《我的路》时从凳子上掉下来的困惑老人。雪莉·麦克雷恩说，在拍摄《相见时难》期间，他让她把口香糖粘在他的耳后。但他有时也喜欢从酒杯里抓一块冰块，塞进一个疯狂粉丝的手心里，并恶狠狠地嘟囔道：“拿着，去上面滑冰吧。”
"I wish someone would hurt you," he told Shirley, "So I could kill them for you."
“我希望有人能伤害你，”他告诉雪莉，“这样我就能为你杀了他们。”
Well, today on our program, of course, Chairman of the Board.
好了，今天我们的节目是关于董事会主席的。
Act One of our program, The Death of Frank Sinatra. Michael Ventura reads from his novel of the same name.
节目的第一幕，《弗兰克·辛纳屈之死》。迈克尔·文图拉朗读他同名小说中的片段。
Act Two, A Modest Request to all of American Television from one Sinatra Fan on Her Knees.
第二幕，《一位跪着的辛纳屈粉丝对美国电视界的谦卑请求》。
Act Three, History Lesson. For the young people.
第三幕，《历史课》。为了年轻人。
Act Four, Frank Sinatra Has a Cold. We have Gay Talese on the program reading from his classic 1966 account of several weeks he spent following Frank Sinatra at the height of Sinatra Rat Pack power.
第四幕，《弗兰克·辛纳屈感冒了》。我们邀请盖·特立斯在节目中朗读他1966年的经典报道，讲述他追踪弗兰克·辛纳屈处于“鼠党”权力巅峰时期的几周经历。
Act Five, A Restaurant Full of Cabbies Gets Choked Up Over Frank. Stay with us, pally.
第五幕，《一间满是出租车司机的餐馆为弗兰克动容》。和我们在一起吧，老兄。
Act One, The Death of Frank Sinatra. Michael Ventura grew up in the 1950s in New York.
第一幕，《弗兰克·辛纳屈之死》。迈克尔·文图拉在20世纪50年代的纽约长大。
I'm Sicilian on both sides of my family. And if you grew up as a Sicilian kid in the '50s in New York, it was like Sinatra was part of your family. He was the most famous Italian, except for some baseball stars. Literally, just a figure people gossiped about, and they listened to his songs, and he was held up to me by my father as an example. You see him? He can spit in anybody's eye and get away with it.
我父母双方都是西西里人。如果你在50年代作为西西里孩子在纽约长大，辛纳屈就像是你的家人一样。他是最著名的意大利人，除了几位棒球明星之外。他简直就是一个让人们议论纷纷的人物，大家听他的歌，我父亲也一直以他为例教育我。你看他了吗？他可以朝任何人的眼睛吐口水而安然无恙。
When Michael Ventura published a novel in 1996 called The Death of Frank Sinatra , Sinatra's people were not pleased. The book, however, is not literally about Frank Sinatra. It's about men like Michael Ventura whose sense of style and sense of self came, in part, from Frank's style.
当迈克尔·文图拉在1996年出版了一本名为《弗兰克·辛纳屈之死》的小说时，辛纳屈的团队并不高兴。然而，这本书并不是真的关于弗兰克·辛纳屈。它是关于像迈克尔·文图拉这样的人，他们的风格感和自我感在一定程度上来源于弗兰克的风格。
What's it mean to you, The Death of Frank Sinatra ?
对你来说，《弗兰克·辛纳屈之死》意味着什么？
The death of a style. The death of the last and greatest embodiment of a kind of street elegance, a style that is particularly and indelibly 20th century and that we will not see again.
一种风格的消亡。最后也是最伟大的街头优雅的化身，一种特别且不可磨灭的20世纪风格，我们将不再看到它了。
Frank Sinatra himself only appears in the book once. In the scene that he's in, he's doing a concert. And one of the things that's interesting is that in a work of fiction, Michael Ventura could choose any era Sinatra concert to put in. And he decided to choose Sinatra in the mid-1990s. The reason why, he says, is because the Sinatra that exists for us today is the Sinatra of all of his ages. All of them come forward as he sings. We asked him to read his account of what Sinatra is, as rendered in this one concert.
弗兰克·辛纳屈本人在书中只出现过一次。在他出现的那个场景里，他正在举办一场音乐会。有趣的是，在虚构作品中，迈克尔·文图拉可以选择辛纳屈任何时代的演唱会来描写。他决定选择90年代中期的辛纳屈。他说，原因在于，今天存在于我们心中的辛纳屈，是他所有年龄段的集合。他唱歌时，所有这些形象都显现出来。我们请他朗读他关于这一场演唱会中所呈现的辛纳屈的描述。
As the old man walked out onto the stage, a curtain came up behind him to reveal a large orchestra. Every musician wore a tuxedo. The conductor was a small, round man sitting at a grand piano and wearing earphones. With a slash of the conductor's hand, the rhythm and brass burst into a loud, uptempo number, and Sinatra flashed a smile that made him look uncannily young, a young smile in the old, pasty face.
当老人走上舞台时，身后的幕布拉开，露出了一个大型管弦乐队。每一位音乐家都穿着燕尾服。指挥是一个身材矮小、圆脸的男人，戴着耳机坐在三角钢琴前。随着指挥手一挥，节奏和铜管乐器爆发出一首高昂、快节奏的曲子，辛纳屈露出了一个让他看起来出奇年轻的微笑，一张苍老而苍白的脸上露出了年轻的微笑。
And his eyes were the same as they'd always been, brighter in person than they ever registered on screen. And like the smile, the eyes were young to the point of seeming unnatural. For though no makeup could conceal the sad ravages of the face, the eyes and the smile seemed untouched.
他的眼睛和往常一样，比在银幕上呈现出的更明亮。就像那个微笑一样，他的眼睛年轻得近乎不自然。因为尽管没有任何化妆能掩盖脸上的悲伤残迹，但他的眼睛和微笑似乎从未被触动。
As though to put his listeners at ease with these contradictions, Sinatra grabbed the microphone from the top of the black grand piano and sang about how they made him feel so young. These strangers in this room had that power. They made him feel so young, and he would feel that way even when he was old and gray. The song itself was keeping him alive.
仿佛是为了让听众对这些矛盾感到自在，辛纳屈从黑色三角钢琴顶上抓过麦克风，唱起他们如何让他感到如此年轻。房间里的这些陌生人拥有这种力量。他们让他感到如此年轻，即使在他年老苍老时，他也会保持这种感觉。这首歌本身就在让他活下去。
It was as though Sinatra's voice was living his entire life all over again at different stages throughout the song. The first bars were the voice of the old man, raspy, worn, unable to hold notes for longer than a beat. And only his mastery of rhythm kept the song alive and made each word surprising. Surprising, though everyone in the room knew the lyrics by heart.
仿佛辛纳屈的声音在整首歌中一遍又一遍地重演他的一生。开头几小节是老人的声音，沙哑、疲惫，无法保持一个节拍以上的长音。只有他对节奏的掌控才让这首歌存活下来，并让每个词都充满惊喜。尽管房间里的每个人都熟记歌词，但这依然令人惊喜。
Then on a high note, the voice cracked, and for an instant, the music soured, and the audience flinched as one person. But instead of retreating from that bad sound, Sinatra leaned into it. Sinatra bent the note further into a jazz-like harmony. And so he erased his mistake from memory by making it part of the performance.
然后，在一个高音上，他的声音破了，一瞬间，音乐走了调，观众不约而同地畏缩了一下。但辛纳屈没有回避那糟糕的声音，而是迎难而上。辛纳屈将那个音符进一步弯曲成类似爵士乐的和声。就这样，他通过将其变成表演的一部分，从记忆中抹去了他的失误。
And then, instead of softening after the mistake, Sinatra held the new note longer and louder as though diving into it, then took a quick breath and sang the next note louder still and fuller, until seamlessly, for several bars, it was the voice of 30 or 40 years ago, full and unfettered, resonant and suggestive, until again it began to crack.
然后，在失误后，他没有软化，而是把那个新音符唱得更长、更响，仿佛沉浸其中，然后快速吸了一口气，将下一个音符唱得更响、更饱满，直到连续几小节，那声音无缝切换成了三四十年前的声音，饱满、奔放、悠扬且充满暗示，直到它再次开始破音。
And again, he used the cracking to modulate back into the voice and style of the old man, on pitch but raw, one note per beat, sometimes right on the beat, sometimes just off it, keeping the performance tense, until on the last note, the young man's voice returned, as though saluting the old man who sang it. And Sinatra let that note ride, and the audience cheered. It was a breathless performance, like watching a trapeze artist work without a net.
他又一次利用这种破音来调回老人声音和风格，音准仍在但显得粗糙，一拍一个音，有时准，有时稍微偏离，保持了表演的紧张感，直到最后一个音符，年轻人的声音又回来了，仿佛在向那个唱出它的老人致敬。辛纳屈让那个音符延续，观众欢呼起来。这是一场令人窒息的表演，就像看着空中飞人在没有安全网的情况下工作。
With barely a pause, he started to sing of how the best was yet to come, and wouldn't it be fine? An old man in some ageless space who could make them believe for the length of a song that the best indeed was yet to come. And the voice again going to and fro between strength and fragility, youth and age. Sinatra's foot tapped the beat with absolute certainty, while his posture was ever so slightly wobbly, as though his energy was too much for his body. And in his immaculate tuxedo with the surety of his presence and the reckless confidence of his style, he seemed to be demonstrating his legend without trading on it, without needing to.
几乎没有停顿，他开始唱最好的还在后头，这难道不好吗？一个在永恒空间里的老人，能让人们在歌声中相信最好的确实还在后头。声音在力量与脆弱、青春与苍老之间来回切换。辛纳屈的脚绝对精准地打着拍子，而他的姿态却微微摇晃，仿佛他的能量超出了他的身体承受力。在他那无可挑剔的燕尾服中，凭着他存在的确定性和他风格中那种鲁莽的自信，他似乎在展示他的传奇，却不需要依靠它，不需要借助它。
The lyrics were trite, obvious, sentimental. Somehow, he made them true. The music was simple to the point of childishness. Somehow, he made it complex. They found themselves applauding and cheering at the songs and not in homage, but as the only way to release the energy it gave them.
歌词陈腐、直白、伤感。不知为何，他让它们变得真实。音乐简单到近乎幼稚。不知为何，他让它变得复杂。他们发现自己为这些歌欢呼喝彩，不是出于崇敬，而是因为那是释放歌曲带给他们的能量的唯一方式。
The man was dispensing something, a kind of vitality that surged from his darkness with bright light. And he was giving it away with generous abandon as though he had no fear that he would not have more to give in the next song, the next show, the next anything. In such an old man, where could this vitality come from?
这个人在散发着某种东西，一种从他的黑暗中涌出的充满光明的生命力。他慷慨地将其散发出去，仿佛他不担心在下一首歌、下一场演出或任何事情中没有更多东西可以给予。在这样一位老人身上，这种生命力从何而来？
I lit my cigarettes like he did. I wore the kind of clothes he wore. I still do. I tried to stand as he stood. I tried to walk as he walked. I still do. Not because I was imitating him but because I was imitating all the people who gave and taught me life, and they took so many of their cues from him.
我像他一样点烟。我穿着他那样的衣服。我现在依然如此。我试图像他那样站立。我试图像他那样行走。我现在依然如此。不是因为我在模仿他，而是因为我在模仿所有给予我生命、教导我生命的人，而他们从他那里得到了太多的暗示。
And where had he taken his cues from? From peasants who came to America from an older, less sentimental world. Peasants who came with the intention of becoming aristocrats, and who almost as soon as they arrived began to stand and walk like those aristocrats they'd watched so closely, yet from afar, for generations. European princes had taught them grace. American streets taught them flare. They didn't need to learn violence from anyone. That they were born with.
他从哪里得到的暗示？来自从更古老、不那么感伤的世界来到美国的农民。这些农民怀着成为贵族的意图来到这里，几乎在他们到达后不久，就开始像那些他们曾近距离观察、却世代遥不可及的贵族一样站立和行走。欧洲王子教给了他们优雅。美国街道教给了他们风度。暴力不需要向任何人学习。那是他们与生俱来的。
And Sinatra blended all this better than any and sang as he did so. Sang of love and of pride, despairing of one and reveling in the other. And this is why Sicilians especially gave him respect in the peculiar way Sicilians use that word, meaning homage, deference, consideration, and that invitation to betrayal, loyalty. Now Sinatra sang about how they-- whoever they were-- couldn't take that-- whatever that was-- away from him. But somehow in the way she held her hat and the way she sipped her tea was beyond the world's possibility to destroy or erode.
辛纳屈很好地融合了这一切，并在唱歌时展示出来。他歌唱爱与骄傲，对前者感到绝望，在后者中沉醉。这就是为什么西西里人对他表现出尊重，这种尊重带着西西里人使用这个词的特殊含义，意味着敬意、服从、体贴，以及那对背叛的邀请——忠诚。现在辛纳屈唱着他们——无论他们是谁——无法把那个——无论那个是什么——从他身边夺走。但不知何故，她拿帽子的方式、她啜饮茶水的方式，超出了世界所能毁灭或侵蚀的可能。
There was a scrapbook of Sinatra's pictures. The pictures were all of Sinatra but he was never alone. Sinatra with Lyndon Johnson, with Adlai Stevenson, with Eleanor Roosevelt. He was holding her hand and looking into her eyes. With Jack Kennedy, Bobby, Jackie, Nixon, Reagan, Nancy. And Sinatra with very different people. Sinatra with Johnny Roselli, Paul Castellano, Carlo Gambino, Carlo's son Joey, Jimmy Fratianno, Sally Spatola.
有一本辛纳屈的相册。照片里全都是辛纳屈，但他从不孤单。辛纳屈与林登·约翰逊、阿德莱·史蒂文森、埃莉诺·罗斯福在一起。他握着她的手，凝视着她的眼睛。与杰克·肯尼迪、鲍比、杰基、尼克松、里根、南希在一起。还有与非常不同的人在一起。辛纳屈与约翰尼·罗塞利、保罗·卡斯特拉诺、卡洛·甘比诺、卡洛的儿子乔伊、吉米·弗拉蒂亚诺、萨利·斯帕托拉。
And still another kind. Sinatra with Marilyn Monroe, Lauren Bacall Humphrey Bogart, Marlon Brando, Louis Armstrong, Elvis Presley, Duke Ellington. That man on the stage, that old man was where it all connected. Who else had held the hand of Eleanor Roosevelt and shaken the hand of Carlo Gambino both and on equal terms. That man on the stage, that old man.
还有另一种人。辛纳屈与玛丽莲·梦露、劳伦·白考尔、亨弗莱·鲍嘉、马龙·白兰度、路易斯·阿姆斯特朗、猫王、艾灵顿公爵。台上那个男人，那个老人，是这一切连接的地方。还有谁能同时握住埃莉诺·罗斯福的手，又以平等的身份与卡洛·甘比诺握手？台上那个男人，那个老人。
And why? Because he could sing love songs like no one else. History of a kind. History transfixed by love songs. That's life, that's what all the people say, the man is singing now. Some people get their kicks from stomping on a dream, but he don't let that get him down. And now he's singing that we're much too marvelous for words. The man was speaking now. "I'm just waiting for a downbeat, not a bus. Where you working tomorrow?" The musicians laughed. The conductor, that little round man, laughed. "That's my son, the guy with the earphones. I had to promise his mother I'd give the bum a job." More laughter.
为什么？因为他能唱出无人能及的情歌。一种历史。被情歌定格的历史。那便是人生，现在那个人正唱着所有人都说的话。有些人从践踏梦想中寻找快感，但他不会让那让他消沉。现在他唱着我们好得太离谱了。那个人现在正说着话。“我只是在等起拍，不是在等公车。你明天在哪儿工作？”音乐家们笑了。指挥，那个圆脸小个子，笑了。“那是我儿子，戴耳机的那个。我不得不向他妈保证，我会给这个混蛋一份工作。”更多的笑声。
But something was wrong on the stage. The music was playing, but Sinatra wasn't singing. He was looking around as though he's forgotten where he was. He started a lyric, then stopped. It didn't fit the music. He looked frightened, a scared boy in the body of an old man. He turned toward his son, whose presence seemed to remind him of who he was. He was Frank Sinatra. He was there to sing love songs to history.
但台上出了问题。音乐在响，但辛纳屈没在唱。他环顾四周，仿佛忘了自己在哪儿。他开始了一句歌词，然后停下了。它与音乐不合拍。他看起来很惊慌，一个老头身体里的受惊男孩。他转向他的儿子，儿子的在场似乎提醒了他自己是谁。他是弗兰克·辛纳屈。他来这里是为历史唱情歌的。
And he wheeled around and began to beg, but in the proudest terms, that luck be a lady tonight, and that she keep the party polite, and that she not blow on some other guy's dice. But it had been an awful moment, to see that confidence suddenly abandoned with nothing in the man to take its place.
他转过身开始恳求，但用的是最自豪的措辞，请求幸运女神今晚做一个淑女，让派对保持体面，不要向别人的骰子吹气。但这真是个糟糕的时刻，看到那自信突然放弃，而那人身上却没有任何东西可以取代它。
He sang more slowly now, that it seemed we'd stood and talked like this before, and he was right. That we'd looked at each other in the same way then, but there was no way to remember where or when. He sang in the young voice and the old, back and forth, where and when unknowable. And as the lyrics climbed to the final high note, he became in his voice younger and younger until we hit the last when roundly and fully and held that note a long time.
他现在唱得更慢了，仿佛我们以前站着聊过天，他是对的。那时我们以同样的方式看着对方，但无法记住在何处或何时。他用年轻和苍老的声音来回切换，在不可知的何处与何时之间。随着歌词攀升到最后的最高音，他的声音变得越来越年轻，直到我们圆满地达到最后的那个音，并长久地保持着它。
And when the note and the word were finally exhausted, the loose muscles of his fatty face trembled, as though they'd been unaccountably left behind, and his eyes were frightened again. He had to know that it was very possible that this was the last time his voice would rise to such a height. And he looked like an old man who had said an irreparable goodbye.
当那个音符和歌词终于耗尽时，他肥胖脸上的肌肉颤抖着，仿佛被莫名其妙地抛在身后，他的眼睛再次变得惊恐。他一定知道，他的声音很有可能再也无法达到那样的高度。他看起来像一个说了永别的人。
He took a few steps, tried to recover. Slowly, he started to speak. "I'm what they call a saloon singer." For most of the performance, he had been singing happily about love, jauntily. Perhaps that was, in part, a function of age. It was easier with that ravaged and undependable voice to sing faster tempos that gave him the flexibility to go through many changes and use many approaches. Slow, sad songs required rounded tones and more control, could not be played with as easily, were far more dangerous. He's risking humiliation every moment. Say what you like. That's a very brave man.
他走了几步，试图恢复。他慢慢开始说话。“我是你们所说的酒吧歌手。”在大部分演出中，他一直在快乐、轻快地唱着爱。也许这部分是年龄的因素。用那种苍老且不可靠的嗓音，唱更快的节奏更容易，因为那给了他灵活切换和使用多种处理方式的空间。慢而伤感的歌需要圆润的音调和更多的控制力，不能轻易玩弄，要危险得多。他每时每刻都在冒着被羞辱的风险。随便你怎么说。那是一个非常勇敢的人。
The song began. He's telling us to drink up, all we happy people. Nobody here looks very happy, but he's admitting that we're happier than him. He says he's paying for the drinks and the laughs. He's paying for everything because a woman with angel eyes is gone. And she's really gone. What a tenderness he has for her. What a terrible, generous, all-encompassing tenderness. He's not bitter. He's not angry at her. Those angel eyes had every right to look elsewhere.
歌曲开始了。他叫我们干杯，所有快乐的人们。这里没有人看起来很开心，但他承认我们比他开心。他说他在为酒水和笑声买单。他在为一切买单，因为一个有着天使之眼的女人离开了。而且她真的离开了。他对她有着怎样的温柔。多么可怕、慷慨、包罗万象的温柔。他不苦涩。他不生她的气。那些天使之眼有权看向别处。
He asks us to excuse him because he must disappear. And his voice is disappearing with him, a scratchy whisper like an old wax record played on an old machine. With unbearable politeness, with a tenderness close to death-- the death of his voice-- he is saying, excuse me, I must disappear. There are no angel eyes left in the room, no reason to stay.
他请求我们原谅他，因为他必须消失。他的声音也随他而去，像是在旧机器上播放的旧蜡盘唱片，发出沙沙的耳语。带着难以忍受的礼貌，带着一种接近死亡——他的声音的死亡——的温柔，他在说，原谅我，我必须消失。房间里已经没有天使之眼了，没有留下来的理由了。
He's tired. He could not live unless he sang to us. But each time he sings, he dares humiliation. Let's us watch the dying relationship between him and his voice, him and his memory, him and that angelic one whom he could not hold, whom he was no man for, whom his tenderness could finally not sustain, whom his darkness drove away. Everything has ended. Everything is over.
他累了。除非他给我们唱歌，否则他活不下去。但每次他唱歌，他都敢于面对羞辱。让我们看着他和他的声音、他和他的记忆、他和那个他无法挽留的、他不配拥有的、他的温柔最终无法维持的、他的黑暗所驱赶走的天使之间的死亡关系。一切都结束了。一切都完了。
He can't even say "excuse me" anymore. He thanks us. He's leaving us. He touched what we like to think was our history, and it has left him like this. And now he is leaving us. Everyone cheered as he walked off the stage. Do they know what they're cheering? Do they know they're watching a man rehearse his death?
他甚至不能再说“原谅我”了。他感谢我们。他离开了我们。他触碰了我们喜欢认为是历史的东西，而它让他变成了这样。现在他正在离开我们。当他走下舞台时，每个人都在欢呼。他们知道他们在欢呼什么吗？他们知道他们正在看着一个人在排演他的死亡吗？
We put one in every performance, if you've seen us perform before. And it's called a saloon song. I do one in each performance because somebody, somewhere, sometime, dubbed me the saloon singer. So I don't want to disappoint him. And it would happen to have a lot of truth, in fact, to that too, because when I was very young and I started working in joints in New Jersey and bars and grills and all kinds of places until one day, somebody came in and offered me a better job. Look what happened to me.
如果你以前看过我们的表演，就会知道我们在每一场演出中都会安排一首。它被称为酒吧歌曲。我在每场演出中都唱一首，因为有人，在某个地方，在某个时间，称我为酒吧歌手。所以我不想让他失望。事实上，这确实包含了很多事实，因为当我年轻时，我开始在纽约、酒吧、烧烤店和各种地方工作，直到有一天，有人进来给了我一份更好的工作。看看我发生了什么。
[MUSIC - "ANGEL EYES" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈的《天使之眼》]
Act Two, One Sinatra Fan Versus All of Network TV. Our program today was first broadcast a few years back when Frank Sinatra was still alive. And in the original broadcast, writer Sarah Vowell made a plea to American television newscasters and a prediction about what would happen when Sinatra finally died. Here's what she said. I'll tell you at the end of her story whether her prediction came true.
第二幕，一位辛纳屈粉丝对抗整个电视网。我们今天的节目几年前首次播出时，弗兰克·辛纳屈还活着。在最初的广播中，作家萨拉·沃威尔向美国电视新闻主播提出了请求，并预测了辛纳屈去世时会发生什么。以下是她的话。在她的故事结尾，我会告诉你她的预测是否成真。
Any day now, Peter Jennings will cut away from some freak mudslide story, casualties, six registered voters, face another camera, and announce Old Blue Eyes' death. Later, the World News Tonight credits will roll over a tasteful montage of Frank's film stills and album covers. The other networks will run similar tributes, as will the brainiacs at Entertainment Tonight and those swingers on The News Hour at PBS.
随时，彼得·詹宁斯都会从某个怪异的泥石流故事、伤亡人数、六名登记选民中切断信号，面对另一台摄像机，宣布“老蓝眼”的死讯。稍后，《今夜世界新闻》的演职员表将滚动播放弗兰克电影剧照和专辑封面的优雅蒙太奇。其他电视网也会播放类似的悼念，PBS的《新闻一小时》里的那些摇摆客也一样。
But you know what? It will not matter whether Sinatra's video wake is hosted by the tweedy Jim Lehrer or the perky Katie Couric because each and every remembrance will be accompanied by the same damn song, the most obvious, unsubtle, disconcertingly-dictatorial chestnut in the old man's vast and dazzling backlog-- "My Way." When the guy who generously gave us greats like "I Get a Kick Out of You" kicks it, we won't put on our Basie Boots or get a load of those cuckoo things he's been saying. We'll be bored terrifically, screaming at the TV set every time he and that sappy string section face the final curtain.
但你知道吗？辛纳屈的录像葬礼是由书呆子气的吉姆·莱勒还是活泼的凯蒂·库里克主持并不重要，因为每一场悼念都会伴随着同一首该死的歌，那是这位老人生前海量且令人眼花缭乱的作品中，最明显、最缺乏深度、最令人尴尬地专断的一首陈词滥调——《我的路》。当慷慨地为我们提供了诸如《我为你疯狂》这样伟大作品的人撒手人寰时，我们不会穿上我们的贝西靴，也不会去听那些他一直在说的疯狂话。我们会感到极其厌烦，每次当他和那些伤感的弦乐组面对最后的帷幕时，都会对着电视机尖叫。
[SINGING] And now, the end is near. And so I face the final curtain.
[唱歌] 现在，终点近了。所以我面对最后的帷幕。
Get it? He's dead and on tape from the grave talking about how the end is near. Spooky.
明白了吗？他死了，录像带从坟墓里谈论终点如何近了。毛骨悚然。
[SINGING] I've lived a life that's full.
[唱歌] 我过着充实的生活。
The only way "My Way" has ever worked is if the person singing it is dumber than the song, which is why the only successful rendition of it was perpetrated by Sid Vicious. Frank-- and Elvis, for that matter-- was always too complicated, too full of rhythmic freedom to settle into the song's simplistic selfishness. "My Way" pretends to speak up for self-possession and personal vision when really, it only calls forth the temper tantrums of two-year-olds, or perhaps the last words spoken to Eva Braun.
《我的路》唯一能奏效的方式是，演唱它的人比这首歌本身更蠢，这就是为什么唯一成功的版本是由席德·维瑟斯演唱的。弗兰克——还有猫王，就此而言——总是太复杂，太充满节奏的自由，无法沉入这首歌简化后的自私。 《我的路》假装为自我占有和个人愿景辩护，而实际上，它只会唤起两岁孩子的发脾气，或者也许是留给爱娃·布劳恩的最后遗言。
Remember the stories from Belgrade, how each night when the government-controlled evening news aired, the townspeople blew whistles or banged on pots and pans so they wouldn't hear the state's lies? Keep that beautiful action in mind when Sinatra's dead, and all the TVs in your more boring democratic world are playing "My Way." Drown it out. Play something else to the montage in your own heart. Or just turn off the TV's sound. Have your stereo queued up and ready to go. He could keel over any second. I mean, he might not even make it through this hour-long radio show. Be prepared.
还记得关于贝尔格莱德的故事吗，每天晚上当政府控制的晚间新闻播出时，镇民们都会吹哨子或敲打锅碗瓢盆，这样他们就不会听到国家的谎言？当辛纳屈去世，当你所在那个更无聊的民主世界里的所有电视都在播放《我的路》时，请记住这个美丽的行动。淹没它。在你自己的心里为这蒙太奇播放点别的什么。或者直接关掉电视的声音。准备好你的音响。他随时可能倒下。我是说，他甚至可能无法撑过这个一小时的广播节目。做好准备。
Why not play "Angel Eyes" for its subtle reference to the singer's Mediterranean windows to the soul, for its knowing, jaunty adieu.
为什么不播放《天使之眼》，因为它对歌手地中海式的灵魂之窗有微妙的暗示，因为它那通透、轻快的告别。
[SINGING] Excuse me while I disappear.
[唱歌] 原谅我消失。
Are you listening, Peter Jennings? Hear how great that would work under all those postwar black-and-white snapshots. How that nice Christian harp outro hints at Frank's unlikely salvation. Let's all listen again.
你在听吗，彼得·詹宁斯？听听这在所有那些战后黑白快照下效果会多好。那美妙的基督教竖琴结尾如何暗示弗兰克那不可能的救赎。让我们再听一遍。
[SINGING] Excuse me while I disappear.
[唱歌] 原谅我消失。
I admit this may not be quite stupid and obvious enough for network television, so if the staff of The Today Show is hearing my voice right now, here's another suggestion.
我承认这对于电视网来说可能不够愚蠢和直白，所以如果《今日秀》的工作人员现在正听着我的声音，这里有另一个建议。
[SINGING] That's life. That's what all the people say. You're riding high in April, shot down in May.
[唱歌] 这就是人生。这就是所有人说的。你在四月春风得意，五月却被击落。
If "Angel Eyes" is all periods and pauses, this song is all exclamation points. Picture please, Good Morning America staffers, quick-cut shots of Sinatra with Ava Gardner, Sinatra with daughter Nancy at age five, Sinatra with Kennedy. Sinatra with some mob boss no one will recognize anyway over these lyrics.
如果说《天使之眼》全都是句号和停顿，那这首歌全都是感叹号。《早安美国》的工作人员们，请想象一下，快速剪辑弗兰克与艾娃·加德纳、与五岁的女儿南希、与肯尼迪的镜头。弗兰克与某个谁也认不出来的黑帮头目在这些歌词下闪过。
[SINGING] I've been a puppet, a pauper, a pirate, a poet, a pawn and a king. I've been up and down and over and out, and I know one thing. Each time I find myself flat on my face, I pick myself up and get back in the race. That's life.
[唱歌] 我曾经是个傀儡、穷人、海盗、诗人、棋子和国王。我经历过起起落落，我知道一件事。每次我发现自己趴在地上，我都会爬起来继续参加比赛。这就是人生。
It's really a terrible choice, just as corny as "My Way," but at least it's got a little bit of the old ring-a-ding-ding. It swings. This is my ABMY vote-- Anything But "My Way." As for me, when I hear the big news, I'm tempted to think I'll be cranking up my favorite Sinatra side, "Come Dance With Me," but it's too disrespectfully cheerful to work as a dirge and kind of creepy, if taken literally. Who, except Tom Petty, wants to foxtrot with a corpse?
这确实是一个糟糕的选择，和《我的路》一样老套，但至少它有一点那种摇摆乐的余韵。它摇摆。这是我的ABMY投票——除了《我的路》什么都行。至于我，当我听到这个大消息时，我本想播放我最喜欢的辛纳屈曲目《和我共舞》，但它作为悼词太不庄重地欢快了，而且如果按字面意思理解有点诡异。除了汤姆·佩蒂，谁想和一具尸体跳狐步舞？
I've decided instead to blare the Capitol recording of Cole Porter's "What Is This Thing Called Love?" It's the driving question behind the entire Sinatra research project, and it's a lovely pop song, suitably melancholy for morning, reflective, and wise. The orchestra starts off low. Enter a clarinet that's somehow lewd and ponderous at the same time. Frank scrawls the topic sentence, then repeats it, adding one word, this funny thing called love. It begins as a rhetorical question, and by the end, turns into a cosmic inquiry of God.
我决定播放科尔·波特《这种东西叫爱情是什么？》的国会唱片版本。这是整个辛纳屈研究项目的背后动力，它是一首优美的流行歌曲，带有适合早晨的忧郁、反思和智慧。管弦乐队从低沉开始。进入一支单簧管，它既下流又笨重。弗兰克写出了主题句，然后重复它，加了一个词，“这种叫爱情的有趣东西”。它最初是一个反问句，最后变成了一个对上帝的宇宙性探究。
[SINGING] What is this thing called love? This funny thing called love? Just who can solve its mysteries? And why should it make a fool of me?
[唱歌] 这种东西叫爱情是什么？这种叫爱情的有趣东西？究竟谁能解开它的谜团？为什么它让我显得如此愚蠢？
Now, ET producers, are you paying attention? At the end of the song, Frank asks one more time to the Lord in heaven above, just what is this thing called love? And then he cuts out, as if he's off to face the creator in person.
现在，ET的制片人们，你们在注意吗？在歌声最后，弗兰克又问了一次天上的主，究竟这种叫爱情的东西是什么？然后他停止了，仿佛他要去亲自面对造物主。
[SINGING] That's why I ask the Lord up in heaven above, just what is this thing called love?
[唱歌] 这就是为什么我问天上的主，这种东西叫爱情究竟是什么？
And then, once he's gone, the orchestra resolves to a sweet, final chord, as if they have the answer, but Frank Sinatra is no longer around to hear it. Can't you just see the freeze frame? Frank in the recording studio, the Capitol years, the hat askew, the tie loosened? TV producers of America, I bet you for all of us, for Frank. Ixnay on the "My Way." Excuse me now while I disappear.
然后，一旦他离开了，管弦乐队转向一个甜美、最终的和弦，仿佛他们有了答案，但弗兰克·辛纳屈已不在身旁听到了。你不能看到那个定格画面吗？弗兰克在录音棚里，国会时期，帽子歪斜，领带松开？美国的电视制片人，我为我们所有人打赌，为了弗兰克。别播放《我的路》。现在原谅我消失。
[MUSIC - "MY WAY" BY SID VICIOUS]
[音乐 - 席德·维瑟斯的《我的路》]
Well, although Sarah Vowell's plea to network television was broadcast twice on our show and once on NPR'S All Things Considered , when Frank Sinatra died on May 14, 1998, just a month after we last played Sarah's commentary, every network newscast used the song "My Way" in its obituary. So much for the power of public radio to alter the national debate.
好吧，尽管萨拉·沃威尔向电视网的请求在我们的节目中播出过两次，也在NPR的《万事皆备》中播出过一次，但当弗兰克·辛纳屈于1998年5月14日去世时，就在我们最后播放萨拉评论的一个月后，每一家电视网新闻报道都在其讣告中使用了《我的路》这首歌。公共广播改变全国辩论的力量也就到此为止了。
The one exception was ABC's Nightline , which is often a maverick force in TV news. The night Sinatra died, Nightline ended its special hour-long tribute to Sinatra by playing Sarah's radio story. In other words, the person who got the last word on American network news that day, the day of Sinatra's passing, was Sarah. Her essay is now collected in her book of radio essays, Take the Cannoli.
唯一的例外是ABC的《夜线》，它经常是电视新闻中特立独行的力量。辛纳屈去世的那天晚上，《夜线》通过播放萨拉的广播故事结束了其一小时的辛纳屈特别悼念节目。换句话说，那天，也就是辛纳屈去世的那天，在美国电视新闻中获得最后发言权的人是萨拉。她的文章现在收录在她的广播散文集《带走甜饼》中。
Coming up, Gay Talese on the road with Sinatra in '66. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来，盖·特立斯讲述66年与辛纳屈在路上的故事。在国际公共广播电台的节目继续之后，一分钟内播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that theme with fiction, nonfiction, radio monologues, whatever we can think of. And the subject of today's show, what was his name again?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过小说、非小说、广播独白，任何我们能想到的方式来尝试这个主题。而今天节目的主题，他叫什么名字来着？
[SINGING] My name is Francis Albert.
[唱歌] 我的名字是弗朗西斯·阿尔伯特。
[SINGING] Francis Albert Sinatra.
[唱歌] 弗朗西斯·阿尔伯特·辛纳屈。
[SINGING] And I sing love songs, mostly after dark, mostly in saloons.
[唱歌] 我唱情歌，大部分在天黑后，大部分在酒吧里。
Yes, you cannot have a career as long and distinguished as Frank Sinatra's without some experiments that fail. Witness Frank Sinatra's cover of "Bad, Bad Leroy Brown" or the Rod McKuen poetry he recorded.
是的，你不可能拥有像弗兰克·辛纳屈那样漫长而杰出的职业生涯而没有一些失败的实验。看看弗兰克·辛纳屈翻唱的《坏坏的勒罗伊·布朗》或他录制的罗德·麦库恩的诗歌。
I can just about get through the day, but the night makes me nervous. Not for any reason except maybe that it catches you unaware and follows you the way a woman follows when she wants something.
我勉强能撑过一天，但夜晚让我感到紧张。没有任何理由，除了可能它让你在不知不觉中被抓住，就像一个女人在想要什么时跟踪你一样。
What is that? The night makes Frank Sinatra nervous? Frank Sinatra? John Connors, who provides a lot of music for our radio program, and has a huge, huge Frank Sinatra collection, was playing me some of these Sinatra turkeys when we had this odd little moment. He was playing me Sinatra's cover of the Simon and Garfunkel hit "Mrs. Robinson."
那是什么？夜晚让弗兰克·辛纳屈紧张？弗兰克·辛纳屈？约翰·康纳斯，他为我们的广播节目提供了很多音乐，并且拥有庞大、庞大的弗兰克·辛纳屈收藏，当我们在那奇特的小时刻时，他正给我播放这些辛纳屈的作品。他正给我播放辛纳屈翻唱西蒙和加丰科尔的热门歌曲《罗宾逊夫人》。
[SINGING] So how's your bird, Mrs. Robinson? Dandy, Mrs. Robinson you say. Hey, hey, hey. Well, have you heard, Mrs. Robinson--
[唱歌] 那么你的鸟怎么样，罗宾逊夫人？很棒，罗宾逊夫人，你说。嘿，嘿，嘿。好吧，你听说过吗，罗宾逊夫人——
It's hard for me to think it's bad because for me, bad is--
我很难认为它很糟糕，因为对我来说，坏是——
Boring.
无聊。
-- is boring. And none of this is boring. I still like them. It's really weird. And it's really weird because these are the songs that made me like him. I'm just thinking of this now because when I was growing up, I didn't hear The Beatles. I heard The Chipmunks doing the Beatles.
——是无聊。而这一切都不无聊。我依然喜欢它们。这真的很奇怪。这真的很奇怪，因为这些歌让我喜欢上他。我只是现在想到这个，因为当我长大时，我没有听过披头士。我听过花栗鼠唱披头士。
Because you are post-baby boom.
因为你是婴儿潮后一代。
I'm post-baby boom. But my mother was going out and was buying Sinatra singing "Mrs. Robinson." So this is the song. This is "Mrs. Robinson" to me. When I hear the Simon and Garfunkel version of "Mrs. Robinson," it's the new version. It's the cover. This is the original. The Simon and Garfunkel version is the cover.
我是婴儿潮后一代。但我妈当时买了辛纳屈唱的《罗宾逊夫人》。所以这就是那首歌。这对我来说就是《罗宾逊夫人》。当我听到西蒙和加丰科尔版的《罗宾逊夫人》时，那是新版本。那是翻唱。这是原作。西蒙和加丰科尔版本是翻唱。
Act Three, So What Makes Sinatra So Special Anyway? From the time of his big breakthrough as a solo singer in 1942, Frank Sinatra simply was more emotionally expressive, more vulnerable, more openly sensual than any male pop singer to that point. But the Frank Sinatra that we think of as Frank Sinatra did not appear until the 1950s.
第三幕，那么到底是什么让辛纳屈如此特别？从1942年作为独唱歌手取得重大突破的那一刻起，弗兰克·辛纳屈在情感表达上就比当时任何男性流行歌手都更丰富、更脆弱、更开放、更感性。但我们认为的那种作为弗兰克·辛纳屈的弗兰克·辛纳屈，直到20世纪50年代才出现。
After a career slump, after his second marriage with Ava Gardner broke up, he went into the studio to record songs with a much more tough, more swinging sound than he had done before. His public image was becoming the character who we know now-- half tough guy, half sentimental saloon singer. And Nelson Riddle invented this sound for these albums with heavy input, apparently, from Sinatra. The '50s are the era of nearly everything we think of today as a Sinatra standard.
在职业生涯低谷，在与艾娃·加德纳的第二次婚姻破裂后，他走进录音棚录制歌曲，声音比以前更强硬、更摇摆。他的公众形象开始成为我们现在所知的角色——半个硬汉，半个伤感的酒吧歌手。尼尔森·里德尔为这些专辑创造了这种声音，显然在辛纳屈的大力投入下。50年代是今天我们认为的辛纳屈标准曲目的几乎所有时代。
[SINGING] Those fingers in my hair, that sly come hither stare that strips my conscience bare, it's witchcraft.
[唱歌] 在我头发里的手指，那个剥掉我良心外壳的狡猾眼神，那是巫术。
Music writer Will Friedwald says that the sound that Riddle invented for Sinatra is built around bass trombone, flute, muted trumpet, and strings. And there's this lightness to the orchestration with a much more complicated mix of melodies and counter melodies on different instruments than other composers were using then on pop records. Witness, for example, how Riddle used trumpeter Harry "Sweets" Edison.
音乐作家威尔·弗里德沃尔德说，里德尔为辛纳屈创造的声音是围绕低音长号、长笛、弱音小号和弦乐构建的。这种编曲有一种轻盈感，与当时其他作曲家在流行唱片上使用的相比，旋律和不同乐器间的对位更复杂。看看里德尔是如何使用小号手哈里·“甜心”·艾迪森的就知道了。
Essentially, he was not hired as a trumpeter to sit in the section, but he was hired strictly as a soloist or an obligatist. And he would not sit in the section. He would sit to the side and had his own special microphone. And so Sweets would just improvise these little trumpet fills here and there on the muted trumpet.
本质上，他不是作为一名坐在声部里的号手被雇佣的，他被雇佣纯粹作为独奏家或伴奏者。他不会坐在声部里。他会坐在旁边，有自己专门的麦克风。所以“甜心”会在弱音小号上即兴演奏这些小号填充音。
And when he plays, he's only playing almost in between the breaths.
当他演奏时，他几乎只在呼吸间隙演奏。
Well, as Gary Giddins points out, Sweets essentially plays three kinds of solos-- beep, beep beep, and beep beep beep.
好吧，正如加里·吉丁斯指出的那样，“甜心”基本上演奏三种独奏——哔，哔哔，和哔哔哔。
Let me play a little bit of this. He comes in here, if I understand, right after Sinatra sings "with people she'd hate."
让我播放一点这个。如果我没理解错，他是在辛纳屈唱完“她讨厌的人”之后进来的。
[SINGING] She loves the theater, but never comes late. She'd never bother with people she'd hate. That's why the lady is a tramp.
[唱歌] 她热爱戏剧，但从不迟到。她从不费心与她讨厌的人在一起。这就是为什么那个女士是个流浪汉。
It's going to come back again in a couple seconds.
再过几秒钟它又会回来。
[SINGING] She'll have no crap games with sharpies and frauds. And she won't go to Harlem in Lincolns or Fords. And she won't dish the dirt--
[唱歌] 她不会玩那些骗子的作弊游戏。她也不会坐林肯或福特去哈莱姆。而且她不会嚼舌根——
Sinatra's at his peak in the '50s and the early '60s. These are the years of his greatest recordings, of his movies, of the Rat Pack. And this all brings us to our next act. Act Four, Sinatra Has a Cold. If we want a glimpse into the life that Sinatra led during his heyday, one of the most famous accounts is by journalist Gay Talese. First published in Esquire magazine in 1966, called Sinatra Has a Cold. It's this long, funny, sad story with many, many, many scenes. We only have time for an excerpt here, which Gay Talese agreed to read for us.
辛纳屈在50年代和60年代初处于巅峰时期。这些是他最伟大录音、电影、鼠党的年代。这一切将我们带到了下一幕。第四幕，《辛纳屈感冒了》。如果我们想窥探辛纳屈鼎盛时期的生活，最著名的记述之一来自记者盖·特立斯。1966年首次发表在《时尚先生》杂志上，题为《辛纳屈感冒了》。这是一个漫长、有趣、悲伤的故事，有很多很多场景。我们只有时间在这里摘录，盖·特立斯同意为我们朗读。
Frank Sinatra, holding a glass of bourbon in one hand and a cigarette in the other, stood in a dark corner of a bar between two attractive but fading blondes who sat waiting for him to say something. But he said nothing. He had been silent during much of the evening except now, in this private club in Beverly Hills, he seemed even more distant, staring out through the smoke and the semi-darkness into a large room beyond the bar where dozens of young couples sat huddled around small tables or twisted in the center of the floor to the clamorous clang of folk rock music blaring from the stereo.
弗兰克·辛纳屈一手拿着一杯波本威士忌，另一只手拿着一根香烟，站在酒吧的阴暗角落里，在两个等待他开口说话、既迷人又逐渐衰老的金发女郎之间。但他什么也没说。他整个晚上大部分时间都很沉默，除了现在，在这家比弗利山庄的私人俱乐部里，他显得更加遥远，透过烟雾和半黑暗，盯着酒吧外一个大房间，那里有几十对年轻情侣挤在小桌子旁，或随着立体声中播放的刺耳民谣摇滚音乐在舞池中央扭动。
The two blondes knew, as did Sinatra's four male friends who stood nearby, that it was a bad idea to force conversation upon him when he was in this mood of sullen silence, a mood that had hardly been uncommon during this first week of November, a month before his 50th birthday. Sinatra had been working on a film that he now disliked and could not wait to finish.
这两个金发女郎和站在附近的辛纳屈的四个男性朋友都知道，在他这种阴沉沉默的情绪下强迫他谈话是个坏主意，这种情绪在11月的第一周，他50岁生日的一个月前，并不罕见。辛纳屈一直在拍一部他现在不喜欢且迫不及待想拍完的电影。
He was tired of all the publicity attached to his dating the 20-year-old Mia Farrow who was not in sight tonight. He was angry that a CBS television documentary of his life, to be shown in two weeks, was reportedly prying into his privacy, even speculating on his possible friendships with mafia leaders. He was worried about his starring role in an hour-long NBC show entitled Sinatra, A Man and His Music, which would require that he sing 18 songs with a voice that, at this particular moment, just a few nights before the taping was to begin, was weak and sore and uncertain.
他厌倦了所有关于他与20岁米娅·法罗约会的宣传，而她今晚没露面。他很生气，据报道，两周后播出的关于他生活的哥伦比亚广播公司电视纪录片正在窥探他的隐私，甚至猜测他可能与黑手党首领的友谊。他担心他在NBC一小时节目《辛纳屈，一个男人和他的音乐》中的主演角色，这需要他在录音开始前几晚，嗓音虚弱、疼痛且不确定时，唱18首歌。
Sinatra was ill. He was a victim of ailments so common that most people would consider it trivial, but when it gets to Sinatra, can plunge him into a state of anguish and deep depression, panic, even rage. Frank Sinatra had a cold. Sinatra with a cold is Picasso without paint, Ferrari without fuel, only worse. For the common cold robs Sinatra of that uninsurable jewel, his voice, cutting into the core of his confidence.
辛纳屈病了。他是普通小病的受害者，大多数人会认为这微不足道，但当它发生在辛纳屈身上时，会让他陷入痛苦、深度的抑郁、恐慌，甚至愤怒。弗兰克·辛纳屈感冒了。感冒的辛纳屈是没颜料的毕加索，没燃料的法拉利，甚至更糟。因为普通感冒剥夺了辛纳屈那颗无法保险的宝石——他的声音，削弱了他自信的核心。
And it affects not only his own psyche but also seems to cause a kind of psychosomatic nasal drip within dozens of people who work for him, drink with him, depend on him for their own welfare and stability. A Sinatra with a cold can, in a small way, send vibrations through the entertainment industry and beyond, as surely as a president of the United States, suddenly sick, can shake the national economy.
它不仅影响他自己的心理，而且似乎在几十个为他工作、与他喝酒、依赖他维持福利和稳定的人中引起了一种心身性的鼻塞。一个感冒的辛纳屈，可以在某种程度上，给娱乐业及其他领域带来震动，就像美国总统突然生病，可以动摇国家经济一样。
For Frank Sinatra was now involved with many things involving many people-- his own film company, his record company, his private airline, his missile parts firm, his real estate holdings across the nation, his personal staff of 75, which are only a portion of the power he is and has come to represent. He now seemed to be also the embodiment of the fully emancipated male, perhaps the only one in America, the man who can do anything he wants. Anything. Can do it because he has the money, the energy, and no apparent guilt.
因为弗兰克·辛纳屈现在参与了许多涉及许多人的事情——他自己的电影公司、他的唱片公司、他的私人航空公司、他的导弹零件公司、他在全国各地的房地产持有、他75人的私人职员，这只是他所是及所代表的力量的一部分。他现在似乎也是完全解放的男性的化身，也许是美国唯一的化身，一个可以做他想做任何事情的男人。任何事情。之所以能做到是因为他有钱、有精力，且没有任何明显的内疚。
All the way. All or nothing at all. This is the Sicilian in Sinatra. He permits his friends, if they wish to remain that, none of the easy Anglo-Saxon outs. But if they remain loyal, then there is nothing Sinatra will not do for them-- fabulous gifts, personal kindnesses, encouragement when they're down, adulation when they're up. They are wise to remember, however, one thing. He is Sinatra, The Boss, Il Padrone.
全力以赴。要么全部，要么全无。这就是辛纳屈身上的西里里人。他允许他的朋友们，如果他们希望保持那样，享受不到任何轻松的盎格鲁-撒克逊式的出路。但如果他们保持忠诚，那么辛纳屈没有什么是不会为他们做的——极好的礼物、个人的善意、他们情绪低落时的鼓励、他们上升时的奉承。然而，记住一件事是明智的。他是辛纳屈，老板，教父。
Or better still, he is what in traditional Sicily have long been called uomini rispetatti-- men of respect. Men who are both majestic and humble. Men who are loved by all and are very generous by nature. Men whose hands are kissed as they walk from village to village. Men who would personally go out of their way to redress a wrong.
或者更好，他是传统的西西里人长期以来所称的“受人尊敬的人”——受尊敬的男人。既庄严又谦逊的人。被所有人爱戴且天生慷慨的人。当他们从一个村庄走到另一个村庄时，人们会亲吻他们的手。那些会亲自去纠正错误的人。
Frank Sinatra does things personally. At Christmastime, he will personally pick dozens of presents for his close friends and family, remembering the type of jewelry they like, their favorite colors, the size of their shirts and dresses. The same Sinatra can, within the same hour, explode in a towering rage of intolerance should a small thing be incorrectly done for him by one of his paisanos. For example, when one of his men brought him a frankfurter with ketchup on it, which Sinatra apparently abhors, he angrily threw the bottle at the man, splattering ketchup all over him.
弗兰克·辛纳屈亲自做事情。在圣诞节，他会亲自为他亲密的朋友和家人挑选几十件礼物，记得他们喜欢的珠宝类型、他们最喜欢的颜色、他们衬衫和裙子的尺寸。同样的辛纳屈，可以在同一小时内，因为他的老乡为他做错了一件小事而爆发出不可容忍的雷霆大怒。例如，当他的人带给他一个上面涂了番茄酱的法兰克福香肠时，辛纳屈显然对此极其厌恶，他愤怒地把瓶子扔向那个人，番茄酱溅了他一身。
In Las Vegas, after the last show at The Sands, the Sinatra crowd, which numbered about 20, all got into a line of cars and headed for another club. It was 3 o'clock. The night was young. They stopped at The Sahara, taking a long table near the back and listened to a bald-headed little comedian named Don Rickles, who was probably more caustic than any other comic in the country. His humor is so rude, in such bad taste, that it offends no one because it's too offensive to be offensive.
在拉斯维加斯，金沙酒店的最后一场演出结束后，辛纳屈的人群，大约20人，都上了一排车前往另一家俱乐部。当时是凌晨3点。夜还很年轻。他们在撒哈拉酒店停下来，在后面占据了一张长桌，听一个名叫唐·里克斯的秃顶小喜剧演员的演出，他可能比全国任何其他喜剧演员都更尖刻。他的幽默非常粗鲁，品味非常糟糕，以至于没有人会被冒犯，因为它太冒犯了以至于无法冒犯。
Spotting Eddie Fisher among the audience, Rickles proceeded to ridicule him as a lover, saying it was no wonder that he could not handle Elizabeth Taylor. And when two businessmen in the audience acknowledged that they were Egyptians, Rickles cut into them and their country's policy toward Israel. And he strongly suggested that the woman seated at one table with her husband was actually a hooker.
在观众中发现了埃迪·费舍尔，里克斯开始嘲笑他作为一个情人的身份，说难怪他搞不定伊丽莎白·泰勒。当观众席上的两个商人承认他们是埃及人时，里克斯抨击了他们以及他们国家对以色列的政策。他强烈暗示那张和丈夫坐在一张桌子上的女人实际上是个妓女。
When the Sinatra crowd walked in, Don Rickles could not be more delighted. Pointing to Sinatra's pal Jilly Rizzo, Rickles yelled, "How's it feel to be Frank's tractor? Yeah, Jilly keeps walking in front of Frank, clearing the way." Then, nodding to Leo Durocher, a former baseball player, Rickles said, "Stand up Leo, show Frank how you slide."
当辛纳屈的人群走进来时，唐·里克斯再高兴不过了。指着辛纳屈的好友吉利·里佐，里克斯大喊：“当弗兰克的拖拉机感觉如何？是的，吉利一直走在弗兰克前面，清理道路。”然后，向曾是棒球运动员的里奥·杜罗彻点头，里克斯说：“站起来，里奥，给弗兰克展示你如何滑垒。”
Then he focused on Sinatra, not failing to mention Mia Farrow, nor that he was wearing a toupee, nor to say that Sinatra's washed up as a singer. And when Sinatra laughed, everybody laughed. And Rickles pointed toward Joey Bishop and said, "Bishop keeps checking with Frank to see what's funny."
然后他关注了辛纳屈，没有忘记提到米娅·法罗，也没有提到他戴着假发，也没有说辛纳屈作为歌手已经完蛋了。当辛纳屈大笑时，每个人都笑了。里克斯指着乔伊·毕晓普说：“毕晓普一直查着弗兰克看什么有趣。”
Then, after Rickles told some Jewish jokes, Dean Martin stood up and yelled, "Hey, you're always talking about the Jews, never about the Italians." And Rickles cut him off, "What do we need the Italians for? All they do is keep the flies off our fish." Sinatra laughed. They all laughed. And Rickles went on this way for nearly an hour until Sinatra, standing up, said, "All right, all right. Come on, get this thing over with. I've got to go."
然后，在里克斯讲了一些犹太笑话后，迪恩·马丁站起来大喊：“嘿，你总是谈论犹太人，从来不谈论意大利人。”里克斯打断他，“我们要意大利人干什么？他们所做的只是把苍蝇赶离我们的鱼。”辛纳屈笑了。他们都笑了。里克斯就这样说了一个多小时，直到辛纳屈站起来说：“好了，好了。来吧，把这事结束掉。我得走了。”
"Shut up and sit down," Rickles yelled, "I had to listen to you sing."
“闭嘴坐下，”里克斯喊道，“我不得不听你唱歌。”
"Who do you think you're talking to?" Sinatra yelled. "Dick Haymes," Rickles replied. And Sinatra laughed again. And then Dean Martin, pouring a bottle of whiskey over his head, entirely drenching his tuxedo, pounded the table.
“你以为你在跟谁说话？”辛纳屈喊道。“迪克·海姆斯，”里克斯回答。辛纳屈再次大笑。迪恩·马丁把一瓶威士忌倒在自己头上，完全浸湿了他的燕尾服，猛击桌子。
By 4:00  AM, Frank Sinatra led the group out of The Sahara, some of them carrying their glasses of whiskey with them, sipping it along the sidewalk and into the cars. And then, returning to The Sands, they walked into the gaming casino. It was still packed with people. Frank Sinatra, holding a shot glass of bourbon in his left hand, walked through the crowd. He, unlike some of his friends, was perfectly pressed, his tuxedo tie precisely pointed, his shoes unsmudged.
凌晨4点，弗兰克·辛纳屈带着这群人离开了撒哈拉，他们中的一些人带着威士忌杯子，在人行道上啜饮并走进车里。然后，回到金沙，他们走进赌博赌场。那里仍然挤满了人。左手拿着一杯波本威士忌的弗兰克·辛纳屈，走过人群。他不像他的一些朋友那样，穿着完美熨烫，燕尾服领带系得恰到好处，鞋子一尘不染。
He never seems to lose his dignity, never lets his guard completely down, no matter how much he has drunk nor how long he's been up. He never sways when he walks like Dean Martin, nor does he dance in the aisles or jump up on the tables like Sammy Davis. A part of Sinatra, no matter where he is, is never there. There's always a part of him, though sometimes a small part, that remains Il Padrone
他似乎从不失去尊严，从不完全放下防备，无论他喝了多少，也无论他熬了多久。他走路时从不摇晃，不像迪恩·马丁，他也不会在过道里跳舞或跳上桌子，不像萨米·戴维斯。辛纳屈的一部分，无论他在哪，都不在那里。总有一部分他，虽然有时只是一小部分，保持着“教父”的状态。
The crowd that had gathered around him now opened to let him through. But a woman stopped in front of him, handing him a piece of paper. He signed it, and then he said, thank you. In the rear of The Sands' large dining room was a long table reserved for Sinatra. The dining room was fairly empty at this hour with perhaps two dozen other people in the room, including a table of four unescorted young ladies sitting near Sinatra.
聚集在他周围的人群现在散开让他通过。但一个女人停在他面前，递给他一张纸。他签了字，然后他说，谢谢。金沙大餐厅的后部有一张为辛纳屈预留的长桌。在这个时间，餐厅相当空，房间里大约有两打其他人，包括坐在辛纳屈附近的一桌四个没有陪同的年轻女士。
On the other side of the room, at a long table, sat seven men shoulder to shoulder against the wall, two of them wearing dark glasses, all of them eating quietly, speaking hardly a word, just sitting and eating and missing nothing. The Sinatra party, after getting settled and having a few more drinks, ordered something to eat. The table was about the same size as the one reserved for Sinatra whenever he's at Jilly's in New York. And the people seated around this table in Las Vegas are mainly the same people who are often seen with Sinatra at Jilly's Restaurant in New York or at a restaurant in California or in Italy or in New Jersey, wherever Sinatra happens to be.
在房间的另一边，在一张长桌上，坐着七个肩膀靠着墙的男人，其中两个戴着墨镜，所有人都安静地吃着，几乎不说一句话，只是坐着、吃着、没有错过任何事情。辛纳屈一行人，在安顿下来并喝了几杯后，点了一些吃的。桌子和辛纳屈在纽约吉利餐厅预留的差不多大。坐在拉斯维加斯这张桌子周围的人，主要是那些经常在纽约吉利餐厅或加利福尼亚、意大利或新泽西的餐馆里与辛纳屈一起看到的人，无论辛纳屈恰好在哪里。
When Sinatra sits to dine, his trusted friends are close. And no matter where he is, no matter how elegant the place may be, there's something of the neighborhood showing because Sinatra, no matter how far he has come, is still something of the boy from the neighborhood. Only now, he can take his neighborhood with him. In some ways, the quasi-family affair at the reserved table in a public place is the closest thing Sinatra now has to home life.
当辛纳屈坐下用餐时，他信任的朋友都在附近。无论他在哪，无论那个地方多么优雅，总会露出一些邻里的样子，因为辛纳屈，无论他走了多远，依然有点像邻里的男孩。只是现在，他可以带上他的邻里。在某种程度上，在公共场所预留桌子上的准家庭事务，是辛纳屈现在拥有的最接近家庭生活的东西。
Gay Talese.
盖·特立斯。
Act Five, How Sinatra Affects Us. We have this account of everyday life from Camden Joy in New York.
第五幕，辛纳屈如何影响我们。我们有来自纽约卡姆登·乔伊的这段日常生活记述。
Recently, a room full of people were almost killed by Frank Sinatra. I was there. I know. The scene was a Turkish kebab house in Lower Manhattan. This is my neighborhood hangout, the sort of place where only the employees are permitted to smoke. I go there because so do a lot of others-- Muslim cabbies on their breaks, fashion students from Kyoto, elegant immigrants from Tehran.
最近，一屋子人差点被弗兰克·辛纳屈害死。我在那儿。我知道。场景是一家位于下曼哈顿的土耳其烤肉店。这是我常去的邻里 hangout，那种只允许员工抽烟的地方。我去那里是因为很多人也去——休息的穆斯林出租车司机、来自京都的时尚学生、来自德黑兰的优雅移民。
So there we all were the other day, eating grilled lamb and deep-fried balls of chickpeas off Styrofoam plates with plastic forks and knives, when suddenly we heard a new sound. A television. Now many of you have already seen televisions, and most of us had too, but the surprise of it in my local kebaberie is that thus far, we'd only heard Turkish radio. So with all due respect, we turned to look at it, as tradition tells you to do whenever anyone switches on a television in your presence.
那天我们大家都聚在那儿，在泡沫塑料盘上用塑料叉子和刀子吃烤羊肉和炸鹰嘴豆球，突然我们听到了一个新声音。电视。现在你们很多人已经看过电视了，我们大多数人也看过，但在我当地的烤肉店里，它的惊喜之处在于，到目前为止，我们只听过土耳其广播。所以出于应有的尊重，我们转过头去看它，正如传统告诉你在有人在你面前打开电视时应该做的那样。
There was a black and white movie. There was a man twitching on a train. There was a woman wearing pearls and a great deal of mascara, hairspray, and lipstick. There was Janet Leigh, and there was Frank Sinatra.
那是一部黑白电影。有一个男人在火车上抽搐。有一个女人戴着珍珠，化着大量的睫毛膏、发胶和口红。那是珍妮特·利，还有弗兰克·辛纳屈。
There are moments in a crowd when America makes so much sense, when you want to scream, bring me your tired, your poor, your hungry, and let's all dig Frank Sinatra. I mean to say this was one such moment. So all of us fell silent as, again, custom holds is the courteous thing to do when a television plays in a public setting. And through the steam of onions browning in olive oil, we watched The Manchurian Candidate .
在人群中总有一些时刻，美国显得如此合理，当你想尖叫，把你疲惫、贫穷、饥饿的人带给我，让我们一起沉迷于弗兰克·辛纳屈。我的意思是这是其中一个时刻。所以我们所有人都陷入了沉默，正如习俗认为在公共场合电视播放时这是礼貌的做法。在橄榄油中褐化的洋葱蒸汽中，我们观看了《满洲候选人》。
Now, I've always wondered why you can never go into a place and hear my favorite Sinatra albums-- his sad albums, like No One Cares or In the Wee Small Hours -- and instead, you only hear songs like "New York, New York." Well, there's a reason. And it's the same reason restaurants have to be careful when his movies are on TV. It's a possible health code violation. You can die from Sinatra.
现在，我一直纳闷为什么你永远不能走进一个地方听到我最喜欢的辛纳屈专辑——那些伤感的专辑，比如《没有人关心》或《在忧郁的小时》，相反，你只听到像《纽约，纽约》这样的歌。嗯，有一个原因。这也是餐馆在电视上播放他的电影时必须小心的原因。这可能违反卫生守则。你可能会因为辛纳屈而死。
In the movie, Sinatra is coming apart. He sets a cigarette between his lips, and it falls into his Scotch and water. He looks around, embarrassed. Only Janet Leigh is watching. He tries to light a match, drops it, manages to light one, but his hands shake too badly, and the match goes out. He asks Janet Leigh whether she minds if he smokes, and their eyes meet, and they fall in love. She tells him she doesn't mind at all. Please do. He tries to light one up again, looks like he's going to vomit, bursts out of his chair, knocks over his drink, and runs.
在电影中，辛纳屈正在崩溃。他把一根香烟放在嘴唇间，它掉进了他的苏格兰威士忌和水里。他环顾四周，感到尴尬。只有珍妮特·利在看。他试图点燃一根火柴，掉了，设法点了一根，但他的手抖得太厉害，火柴熄灭了。他问珍妮特·利她介不介意他抽烟，他们眼神交汇，坠入爱河。她说她一点也不介意。请便。他试图再点燃一根，看起来要吐了，猛地从椅子上跳起来，打翻了饮料，跑了。
There in the Turkish kebab house our mouths were full of baba ghanoush and hummus and baby lamb. But all of us had stopped chewing. We were too struck by what we were seeing. A man we all recognized was on the television about to break down. Sinatra has tried to flee the woman, but she follows him. She asks him where his home is. He can't look at her. His voice catches on every syllable as he tells her he's in the Army. His eyelids flutter. He sucks on the cigarette she has lit for him. He sighs, apparently at everything.
在那家土耳其烤肉店，我们的嘴里塞满了巴巴加努什、鹰嘴豆泥和嫩羊肉。但我们所有人都停止了咀嚼。我们被眼前所见深深震撼。我们都认出的一个男人正出现在电视上，即将崩溃。辛纳屈试图逃离那个女人，但她跟着他。她问他他的家在哪里。他无法直视她。当他告诉她他在军队时，他的声音在每个音节上都卡住了。他的眼睑颤动。他吮吸着她为他点燃的香烟。他叹气，显然是对所有事情。
We all know people who hate Frank Sinatra for all sorts of reasons, mostly for how he treats other human beings in so-called real life. And they dismiss the undeniable beauty of his talent. I wonder if these people had been in the Turkish kebab house with us what they would think, seeing this scene. As with his best albums, Sinatra doesn't seem to be going from any script. There aren't printed-up lyrics and dialogue for this kind of thing. It's the real stuff. In this scene, he says almost nothing. He exhales and sweats and looks away. He's standing before us letting his feelings utterly overwhelm him. It's scary.
我们都知道那些因为各种原因讨厌弗兰克·辛纳屈的人，主要是因为他对待所谓现实生活中其他人对待的方式。他们忽视了他才华无可置疑的美。我想如果这些人当时和我们在土耳其烤肉店，看到这一幕，他们会怎么想。就像他最好的专辑一样，辛纳屈似乎没有遵循任何剧本。对于这种事情没有打印出来的歌词和对话。这是真正的东西。在这个场景中，他几乎什么也没说。他呼气、出汗并看向别处。他站在我们面前，让他的感受完全淹没了自己。这很可怕。
It's time I mention what else was happening in our Turkish kebab house, and that was that all of us-- employees, bike messengers, cabbies-- felt Sinatra's confusion so completely that we ourselves were about to cry. We would have been crying, that is, if our throats weren't clogged up with Turkish cuisine. Sinatra can barely talk. We could barely breathe.
该提到我们在土耳其烤肉店还发生了什么了，那就是我们所有人——员工、自行车快递员、出租车司机——都如此完全地感受到了辛纳屈的困惑，以至于我们自己也要哭了。我们会哭的，也就是说，如果我们的喉咙没有被土耳其菜噎住的话。辛纳屈几乎说不出话。我们几乎喘不过气来。
On the television, Janet Leigh starts to tell Sinatra who she is. Then she stops. Instead, tells him her address, tells him the apartment number, her phone number. She gently asks him if he can remember it. His larynx closes up as he tells her, yes. You aren't sure how to take this response, because he still can't look at her. Janet Leigh repeats the phone number, and he turns even further from her, shakes his head slightly, closes his eyes in weariness.
在电视上，珍妮特·利开始告诉辛纳屈她是谁。然后她停下了。相反，告诉他她的地址，告诉他公寓号码，她的电话号码。她温柔地问他是否记得。当他告诉她，记得时，他的喉咙闭上了。你不知道如何对待这个反应，因为他仍然无法直视她。珍妮特·利重复了电话号码，他进一步转过身去，轻轻摇头，疲惫地闭上了眼睛。
In that moment, finally, after attentively watching this, the whole group of us in the kebaberie began to cough. Most everyone was choking back tears. But by this time, many of us were choking on shish kebab too. We were gagging into napkins, downing our sodas, poking ourselves in the ribs, crossing our hands at our throats. And then, abruptly, just like that, it was gone. We were OK. We would be fine.
那一刻，终于，在专注地看着这一切后，我们整个烤肉店的小组开始咳嗽。大多数人都噎住了眼泪。但这时，我们很多人也被烤羊肉串噎住了。我们对着餐巾纸干呕，灌下苏打水，戳着自己的肋骨，交叉双手放在喉咙处。然后，突然，就像那样，它消失了。我们没事了。我们会好起来的。
We looked up at the television. Sinatra, our would-be killer, was breathing easier too.
我们看向电视。我们的准杀手，辛纳屈也呼吸得更轻松了。
Well, our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike, contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
好了，我们的节目今天由彼得·克劳尼和我自己制作，阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克，特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔、保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和马吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago-- 312-832-3380-- or visit our website, where you can also listen to our shows for free, www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买此节目的录音带，请致电我们芝加哥的WBEZ——312-832-3380——或访问我们的网站，您也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目，www.thislife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who, of course, we always refer to as--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，当然，我们总是称他为——
The Boss. Il Padrone.
老板。教父。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。